hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand chester we are back and in the
finals it's around two and it's Maxine
for sure lagravis is magnus cross and
the first game where Colin had the white
pieces ended in a draw but it was an
extremely tough game for both sides and
well now Maxime was on the attack and it
was he sacrificed a piece it was either
he's gonna do it or not but in the end
somehow it all unwindulaxing stuff if
you haven't seen to check it out I will
even put a link to the game in the
description below so this like I said
again from round 2 and before we check
it out a lot of you have been asking me
that you are not receiving notifications
when I upload a video well there are
there are perhaps several reasons to
that now first is that YouTube cleans
out inactive subscribers there are
sometimes I mentioned this every first
of the month for example if YouTube
thinks you're a bot or maybe you don't
comment on videos maybe you don't leave
likes or dislikes then maybe yeah
YouTube will think that you were bought
and then unsubscribe you so you can
check if you are still subscribed and it
but then again it doesn't even matter if
you're subscribed and even if you have
the little bell icon turned on YouTube
addressed this issue they made a video
about it some two months ago their
servers are overloaded and they cannot
handle sending so much notifications all
at once for example I have over 500,000
subscribers now but when I publish a
video not all 500 of you received the
notification immediately for example
10,000 people will receive it
immediately then maybe during the first
hour maybe maybe up to 20,000 and then I
don't know when when the resources
become available then the other
notifications are sent at least that's
how how I understood the video but that
that's mainly the reason why this is so
and regarding the double ads some of you
have mentioned it's because christmas is
coming and YouTube well YouTube is just
very greedy so you will sometimes get to
ads sometimes there will be two
unskipable ads so sorry about that there
is nothing I can do about that
it's YouTube's doing guy I do not choose
how many as will be shown and will they
be you know what kind of ads they will
be so that's I just wanted to address
that so that being said let's check out
the game MVL wid the white pieces opens
with E for so ready for a nice fight
with E 5 by Magnus nice to have 3 Knight
to c6 and Bishop to b5 the rule opus is
on the board with a six more fees
defense Bishop to a4 Knight to f6 and
now castles offering the e4 pawn
sometimes you will see players grab it
sometimes they will go for for a
different line but here we have Knight
captures on e4 by Magnus as he already
played it against Caruana in zagreb
during the Grantchester and that was a
really also a really crazy game ended in
a draw but ok we have d 4 by m VL Bishop
to e7 and now rook to e1 attacking the
knight here and b5 by Magnus so
everything the same as in the game
corona versus Carlson during done the
Zagreb Ranchester we have rook captures
on e4 and now beef before recapturing an
a4 first Magnus goes d5 attacks the rook
and here comes Knight captures on e5 so
you don't really have the option of
capturing the rook because if rook is
captured the Knight captures and c6
comes with an attack on the Queen and
after we move the Queen you're just
gonna grab another piece and after all
is said and done you're just gonna move
the bishop and you have two pieces for a
rook white will of course to be
completely winning here so after this
Knight captures any 5 we have Knight
captures on e5 by Magnus with rook
captures on e5 and only now Bishop B
captures on e4 on a4 and here the game
continued the the one across and played
against Cora wanna Cora wanna play
tonight the c3 here and then we got a
very exciting position after castles
Quran of course did not go for the d5
form Carolina played route back to e 1
because if you capture yes you do grab a
point but after Bishop to b6
that's that's a monster bishop and after
this bishop guess it gets to b7 it's
gonna be well it's just gonna be a
bishop prepare from Hale so you do not
want to face that
so after this B captures on a4
MBL really I went into a deep think and
in the end he decided to go for b3 he
just wants to develop with Bishop to e3
trade-off the dark square Bishop and you
don't you don't get the capture for
example on b3 because well not because
Bishop to a3 Bishop to e3 seems deadly
now but it's actually not because here
Magnus has b2
I'm just showing it because it's very
interesting and now if you don't want to
allow another Queen into the game you
have to capture it and then just the
Bishop to e6 end of the game continues
but after a character son b3 you could
play a capture some b3 and then just
white gets a nice semi open file for his
rook
so after b3 with castles by Carlson and
the now comes Bishop to e3 offering the
trade of bishops as the best of 27 is
under attack with Bishop characters on
83 Knight captures in 83 and now rook to
e8 and again MVR went into a thing so
far across and really hasn't spent a
second well maybe a minute max on each
move and Emil Spencer at least to 20
minutes on the past two moves
so here again rook captures on e8 he
grabs with Czech Queen captures and now
there is one game in the database were
Knights the b1 was played you want to
shift the night over to the King side
maybe grab hold of the e5 square it's a
nice dark square since black has a light
square bishop and if you want to prevent
this year you're kind of gonna have to
push f6 but here instead of this Knight
maneuver we have Queen to d2 and Queen
to d2 is a new move in the position so
already as a move 15 we have a
completely new game
Magnus goes the bishop to f5 again
without much thinking making it hard for
this night to enter the game not only
can you not go anywhere with the night
other than b1 now you can't even go B 1
because well the c2 point will be
pressured I first looked at a 1 and now
Queen to c6 adding another attacker to
the c2 pawn and now C for getting rid of
this backwards pawn with a capture some
b3 a captures and the now comes h6
Magnus creates a breeding Square for his
skin so you get rid of any background
quick
and now see capture Sun d5 it seems like
not a move you want to play because you
have such such a nice bone structure
here you would like to preserve it you
don't want to break it up but it's hard
hard to not do it and you also need to
bring this night in the game so see
captures and d5 also frees the c-4
square for the night for example if you
play something like c5 hope hope to get
b4 in and try try and not I could get
your pawn structure messed up then you
can just start attacking the b-pawn
queen b7 and you don't really have ways
of defending the pawn the bishop is
about guarding b1 so rugby one doesn't
work you can defend it once with the
Queen but the dangerous rook b8 and you
will now lose the pawn so that's why mvl
goes C captures on d5 with Queen
captures and now Knight to c4 very
interesting but rook to e5 does not win
a piece even though it comes with a
double attack because Queen captures and
b3 now comes with an attack on the
knight and the ones who trade Black is
just up a pawn after such an idea so
first Knights the c4 as you free the c-4
square for your knight and now look the
e5 definitely is a threat so here better
back the east six but now mvl decides to
push the Queen for the back and advance
the D pawn you don't want to wait for
rook to d8 while this point is still
here so look the e5 by mvl pushing the
Queen back Queen d7 and now d5 pushing
the bishop back of course you're not
interested in in moving the bishop so
rook to d8 by Magnus and now comes D
captures on e6 grabbing a bishop
offering a queen trade we have Queen
captures on b2 and now you could go with
the D in between
he captures and f7 chair King captures
but you don't really gain anything by it
you just to go into pretty much the same
end game after g3 making a room for the
king
so here not playing it captures on f7
with just Knight captures and II do rook
captures on d2 now you have to be
careful as there are background issues
so g3 by m VL f captures on e6 by Magnus
rook captures and now we have this
engine where it's four pawns each and
the rook of course
look the a to preparing to go after the
pawn here but also while defending the
a6 pawn so rook the c6 is going after
the c6 pawn but now rook to a3 with rook
actress and c7 rook captures and b3 and
now rook to e7 of course putting a look
behind the passed pawn and even though
it's a it's it's an outside passed pawn
it will be somewhat difficult to make
use of it since white already already
has a rook behind it so rook to a3
defending it and now g4 preparing to
bring the King into the game with h5 and
messing up White's pawn structure G
captures on h5 and now King to h7 it's
okay but white is up upon for a moment
but it's it's a double H bond not much
to be worried about
kingi - we have looked a five going
after the pawn here and now f4 there's
really no point in moving it once the
rook moves you can also capture on a six
so rook the a3 cutting off the white
king but rook to e8 we have a five now
and look back to a6 with a four and now
white pushes f5 and now rook the b3 now
giving up the e4 pawn but then you are
going to collect White's pawns so rook
captures an a4 look the b5 going after
the f5 pawn and rook the f4 defending so
now it's three points to one but still
not not much white white can do about
this to convert it with King to h6 and
now f6 just just trading as there's
really no way to push for any advantage
here G captures with rook captures with
check and King captures on h5 so now
white is up only 1 point 8 4 in boxing
just gives it up since both of them of
course no this is this is a draw rook
captures and beat you with check by
Magnus and BL blocks with captures
captures and we have captures and here
this is the best kind of draw it's a
draw by insufficient material which is
always great when such strong
grandmasters play it out all the way
till the end so there we have it the
second classical game wins ends in the
draw no no free six points for anyone
they will go at it tomorrow in the rapid
section so like we said two more rapid
games
and then for more blitz games and then
the winner from this matchup will face
the winner from the matchup the England
versus level Oregon for the for the true
finals of the Grantchester finals so
that's the game I do hope you enjoy that
I would like to thank pablo mohan
phillips writes up a Steve Foster and
Irfan hodge for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here think of for
watching and I will see you soon
checking up on being versus Oregon are
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and starting the our next
big saga fairly soon so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day